here we are inside the official press
conference for FTTH now as you can see
behind me everyone is beginning to take
their seats and the conference will
begin in a few moments now there really
is the sense here that this is a
worldwide affair we have a hundred or
more and lists and media from all over
the world all here for the same reason
to realize the importance of FTTH and
the objective here today without a doubt
is to spread the ftth message to as many
people as possible
i'm here with roland Montaigne from I
date now Roland what new trends do you
see in the ftth market panorama prepared
by I date for the ftth Council Europe
this year well there is a several main
points of the ftth panorama first in
terms of figures we have a total if you
include the whole Europe I mean with
Russia and all the main countries we
have 19 million subscribers in these
zones quite a lot if we concentrate only
in Russia and Ukraine turkey with a
quite dynamic we have on those countries
alone 9 million subscribers but Europe
even if in political Europe you 27 we
have only i would say six million
subscribers things are progressing we
have today for example already countries
totally covered with fibre-to-the-home
one hundred percent of the homes are
really covered with fiber domes the case
of a neutron iya for for example another
good news for for Europe is that fiber
is progressing in several region in the
European landscape for example thirty
percent of the new subscribers are still
located in the Nordics in Netherlands
thirty percent are more or located in
eastern part of Europe but we see for
the first time that in Western Europe
I'm in countries such as France Portugal
Spain are today representing nearly
fifty six percent of the new subscribers
so things are moving and we are today I
think in a new line of the deployment
and development of fiber to the home in
Europe
hello Stefan now Ventura team along with
Portland advisors looked into the
funding opportunities for FTTH in Europe
what are the conclusions they found well
we were asked how to accelerate our
investment in fiber and we found that
there is plenty of money available the
problem is that the industry is not
going to the capital markets and the
right way so at the moment it would take
about 90 two years at the current rate
of investment to replace all the copper
with fiber many people think that's too
long the interesting thing is that the
industry could fund the switchover
itself completely in about 25 years and
in the way that the regulatory system
works in the bill every month there is
an element paid for the renewal of
infrastructure and at the moment I don't
know what that money has been used for
but it's not going into the local loop
where many of us feel that should go so
over 25 years the industry he was half
of its capex budget could actually fund
the switchover if it was going to be
faster taxpayer would need to contribute
and now with Benoit Felton from
diffraction analysis now diffraction
analysis was commissioned by the ftth
Council Europe to look at the benefits
of FTTH for real estate projects what
were some of the conclusions of this
study well we spoke to a number of real
estate players who have deployed or have
been part of projects deploying fibre to
the home and fibre to the building all
of them were very positive about the
outcomes and essentially it comes down
to two things first of all the ability
to increase the value of the properties
they put on the market whether it's for
rent or for sale and second the ability
to offer new services over fiber that
are relevant for their users such as
home security home management and lower
carbon emission home
and now with dr. Christian cobalt from
datuk on duty Khan was commissioned by
the ftth Council Europe to investigate
how regulatory measures can encourage
investment in fiber access networks can
you give us some examples of
recommendations perhaps yeah i can give
you two very specific examples fiber is
obviously in strong competition with
traditional copper based access product
and customers are often not really aware
what they're getting from standard dsl
product so they don't know what speed
will service quality what reliability
they get which limits what they're
willing to pay for for fiber another way
of potentially we're using an impact
from old copper axis is to allow
incumbents to withdraw Papa based access
products once they've started rolling
out fiber but that's currently not
possible on the regulatory policy
measures so that's something that could
be addressed thank you very much for
taking the time to talk to us dr. cobalt
back to you
you